Ron darling back here on the riches and
show how you doing Ron I'm doing great
the Ritz that clarity on efficient you
got it so uh when you get in that booth
over the weekend there'll be no Carlos
Correa at shortstop and we're seeing him
tweeting out pictures and in the post Oh
our room how do you think this affects a
team that's been on such a role to this
point this well I think that luckily
they have such a big lead that they can
probably afford to take this hit you
know he's one of the greatest players we
have greatest young players that we have
I am sustained the same injury so he
should be back in no time a couple of
months or so but and plus he's so young
but I was just uh I feel bad because I
just wanted to see this young man play
I've only seen him play live maybe half
dozen times
every single time level days so did you
suffer the same injury swinging it back
to I yeah I wish I was thinking about I
usually swung and missed but and really
have a chance to sustain any injuries
but no I I did it a diving for a bunt by
Vince Coleman I had a no-hitter in 1987
into the seventh inning he bunted and I
was trying to make the play to no-hitter
intact and just all my drama that was
the end of that season or on that
subject is that a is that an unwritten
rule of baseball that Vince broke there
do you think it was a one nothing game
so I never took it like that I always
thought that fits this game that was
part of his game of course anyone who
remembers Vince in his great speed so
now not in one second that I ever think
that was the wrong play and in fact when
I was on the mound I anticipated that he
could maybe do that Ron darling here on
the Rich Eisen show the other telecast
that will be on on TBS is going to be
Brewers and Cubs coming up this the
weekend after that and so do you think
the Cubs have turned a corner here
they've won
they've won six in a row they haven't
lost a single game since coming back
from that Paul Starr break well you know
you know the the last game before the
all-star break Jon Lester gave up those
kind of runs yes first inning and it's
probably the lowest point for them all
season long but you know
so from a guy who used to be in the
clubhouse when your management goes out
and gets a picture like Quintana it
really makes you feel in the clubhouse
that you know we know we haven't played
well but our management is behind us
100% we need a little help they went you
got it and and then sometimes I could
permeate a ball club and get a mop quick
start that being said you know the
compass or have a few holes that they
didn't have last year everything is not
going as of finally as it did last year
so they're gonna have to really step on
the pedal it'll be interesting to see if
Milwaukee's got enough they they I
always thought there maybe were two
years away from where they were supposed
to be but I think Eric Thames had a lot
to do with them having that great start
and then you got the Nationals obviously
20 games over 500 I'm wondering if it's
just all just spitting in the wind with
the way that the Dodgers are on such a
roll right now
Ron can you compare this Dodger team
with than any other team that you've
seen in recent days at all yeah you know
I they remind me like they're trying to
pull off what the what the Mariners did
in oh one my memory is not served me
right or was it when for the Mariners
won 116 games I mean it seems like
they're on that kind of role they're the
same kind of role that the Cubs for last
year everything is working I mean Alex
wood is a very good pitcher I don't know
if he's a whether no pitcher Justin
Turner is an outstanding player I don't
know if he's a 370 hitter I feed so all
of these things you know a Bellinger you
bring up and since he's been up there 61
and 14 you know a lot of things have
gone well for them and the foundation of
that team always were strong anyway yeah
I mean you know the numbers that you
just said were somewhat ridiculous and
and their numbers are ridiculous that
the 2001 Mariners didn't even make the
World Series that's a you know the
Yankees knocked them off and there was
you know that's why I'm just wondering
who can get the Dodgers who do you think
could get them
who do you think could just be be the
Yankees of that year to their Mariners
from that year yeah that's that's that's
an interesting I mean you know what Tony
asked us this week so you look at the
Astros and say boy typical colors is on
top of his game Keiko has proved in the
postseason that it can shut down a team
they have so much star power with
Springer and Altuve and pray I'll be
back by then studying veteran influences
and and McCann and Beltran have played a
lot in the postseason you know that that
might might be a team that could kind of
upset them I I always look at the teams
that uh you know the Dodgers had a
pretty amazing season two seasons ago
and Mets were able to beat them in five
games because their pitching was a
little superior at the ground was great
in that series so it would take a team
like a Cleveland like a Houston a team
that controlled some great starting
pitching and especially Cleveland you
got to be seven six innings or or eight
elbows game yeah you need Ron darling
here TBS he's going to be in the booth
of Astros Orioles this Sunday at 1:30
p.m. Eastern Time
you named American League teams Ron I'm
talking about oh maybe just go yeah yeah
a team that just might even beat him in
the unless you think that you just put
the Dodgers in the World Series which is
absolutely understandable yeah yeah I'm
putting the Dodgers in the World Series
I am I just think they're too strong the
too good of a ballclub I think
Washington can be that ballclub if
Doolittle and Madson come over and pitch
the way that they have in the past that
could change their whole dynamic because
when we talk of the elite to use of
baseball's the Dodgers the Astros and
Washington is left out only because of
their bull kind inefficiencies but if
that changes would do little amassing
than Washington is going to be one of
those teams so if you want me to name a
National League team and I am conceding
the World Series Duke Dodgers but if a
national team could stop them it could
be with the Nationals because of a
Harper and Zimmerman and Rend own and on
and on Murphy of course I can read about
because they have the hitting baby
uh to scratch a couple of runs against
that good pitching stuff well I mean you
can't leave out Murphy because there are
at least some Washington Nationals New
York Mets games from to torture the Mets
progress the season it's unbelievable
run oh I've never seen anything like it
it's almost uh I I was saying and at the
and hopefully this doesn't sound too
crass but I think it's going to Murphy
against the Mets is like a dream come
true
for a foot the guy who gets divorced he
gets his money back you don't I mean
it's a the main thing that he is able to
do to the bats um because they did not
offer him a long-term deal he's used
that as a chip on his shoulder and now
to hit 400 and the number of bats that
he's had against the Mets it's just
remarkable now I know front office's
always would say yeah we're looking
forward we're you know we're on to the
next one but do you think at some point
quiet moment Mets organization says
maybe we should actually kept that guy
you think right I'll think about it this
way of the Mets could when they bring up
their young shortstop Rosario have
Rosario at shortstop Daniel Murphy at
second base and Justin Turner at third
he also was guy who was about tendered a
contract by the New York Mets
so that would be certainly an upgrade
for this ballclub so that's a yes is
basically yes oh my gosh Ron hey Ron
always a pleasure chat whether you have
fun with the TBS games and everything
else going on se out of your lovely wife
and we'll chat soon yeah and we'll top
all during the post okay look forward to
it that's Ron darling the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy